welcome to this video playing our
tactical from from Spain again let's see
the cat alone yep we get the Catalan
just playing the clothes catalan just
thinking let's see is this already this
wasn't a good move order really I mean
ok I can play that it's not terrible but
I should have played differently ok so i
can play 92 now to cap a c4 or reform
d4d takes rook t1 i think this is a
playable line but not what i wanted to
do originally you know this is a porn
set off Leslie so II 594 maybe
has a fairly typical point sacrifice
that it's not clear how much
compensation white house here in this in
this specific form of the sacrifice I
maybe can play night before and play
this a bit ago claim night before not
before queen bee one Bishop before it's
not not really great okay so 96 here
okay I don't want to spend so much time
here i hope that this works taking on b7
Bishop g5 this night be seven oops isn't
this good forward I can go to e7 hmm ok
take 95 got 95 okay so probably must do
that rook takes d4 Queenie files not
really great
try to get those pawns here 96 96 maybe
f6 hook do rook c8 is a very annoying
okay so let's go here have success also
night f5 I thought night at five but
maybe Queen f7 then
Quincy 6f a Quincy five King edge a
damn's just about okay for black I mean
air between a son e six takes rook e1
Queen f7 rookie seven now let's call it
a stir
I didn't see that move at all great
before not sure yeah i don't i'm down
one time we know the story the position
i don't really I don't really understand
it seems fairly fairly unclear to me I
have some I have some quite obvious play
by morning night and 10 and things teas
693 I'd just take them yeah 50 seconds
song probably should try to keep it
simple
well allowing f5 is really amazing yeah
now why this right is probably better
probably check it is fairly complicated
so it's not like so easy to to judge
right now is putting his rook totally
offside
I don't have time yeah did that some
check check 20 seconds of stool is too
low for this too little time check
check yeah this does not matter you can
play whatever I wanted win on time he
ate for instance was was winning I think
yeah okay I can resign this light yeah
this is I screwed this up in the when I
spend too much time I mean it was really
why would he allow f5 this is this is
quite amazing okay here why this is
winning of course but i didn't i didn't
manage this was supposed to too little
time and this is of course great just
puts Putin what so 95 is just a flat-out
win + 8 let's check this yeah the pride
sides a check me all night this is the
problem this is a check and this is what
I didn't see and this means yeah okay
he's playing without the rook he
basically blundered this rook on the
corner so yeah this is terribly easy and
I had 40 seconds that's a shame ok this
is also plus 6 rook takes d5 and wins
yeah is playing without the rook I mean
look at we can look at this position if
you want this is the total joke of a
piece I know yeah I took check King f3
is still a draw okay well I couldn't at
20 seconds is to live and I need some
time to check calculate and somewhere
here I probably have drawers or win
syrup ta drawers and so on let's briefly
look
the start of it I made ya b3 b6 every
Queen d3 I don't like this this
particular or no and ok I I know that
this is this as a possible line here
Bishop g5 is probably a bad idea yeah
bishop night before is very good for
black when she didn't play this is not
greater Joe now played this too quickly
stumbling into this this is this is just
not great like it's black it's a piece
up I can muddy the waters but it's
nothing nothing working I thought we'd
thought maybe here but he can still take
here this should be 7s Bishop f3 winning
a piece they were terrible opening by
white yeah this is this is unclear took
a knife form win here and I was amazed
that you played f 6 and 6 seconds but
okay Quincy 6 is also interesting but
probably not sufficient I thought about
this I'm sorry The Ecstatic takes
something like this what has some
serious activity emits about equal
according to the computer this this was
this was interesting a thought I was
expecting Queen f7 of course not Quincy
five and here i thought this would be
interesting
I as a defense d3 Queen takes Knight c5
a nice while okay giving black slight
edge okay buddy went here and now this
is this is a really interesting position
before rook air-five seems to be
interesting c4 rupee 893 yeah I mean
that he allowed fif is simply simply
stunning how can you do that I mean just
rookie six with the slight edge for
black giving me the protected passer
with d5 being lost basically it's quite
remarkable yeah okay whatever thanks for
watching